with vaccine approval potentially just
hours away
our manuel bajorquez is outside pfizer's
freezer farm
in kalamazoo michigan which is one place
where distribution will begin manuel
what will it look like
well good morning anthony it is expected
to be a well choreographed effort
between the vaccine maker
and the nation's shipping giants and it
all begins right here in western
michigan where this pfizer plant
is on standby officials say 6.4 million
doses of the vaccine will leave
warehouses like this one
within 24 hours of approval
we've been looking forward to this day
for a while now kendra piatt will be
among the first to receive the covet 19
vaccine once it's approved
the nurse manager at butterworth
hospital's er in grand rapids michigan
says the shot
represents peace of mind for those
working on the front lines
having the vaccine for us is just the
beginning
to the end of this pandemic spectrum
health is one of five health systems in
michigan prepared for vaccine
distribution
ultra cold freezers required for the
pfizer vaccine
are ready for storage clinic space has
been set aside to dole out almost one
thousand doses
dr russell lampen is the health system's
division chief for infectious diseases
we'll be able to start rolling up
sleeves and giving vaccine as soon as we
have approval
hospitals like those in spectrum health
will be getting the vaccine thanks to a
coordinated effort by pfizer
ups and fedex ups says it's a three-step
process that's already underway
step one shipping vaccine administration
kits containing things like syringes
step two shipping the actual vaccine and
step
three sending dry ice to sites that
don't have the ability to keep the
vaccine
at extreme sub-zero temperatures once
they reach sites like spectrum health
front-line workers will be getting the
first doses as they tackle
a thanksgiving surge in cases the
vaccine couldn't come
at a better time but dr lampen warns at
this early stage a vaccine
isn't going to work on its own we need
to keep doing the things that we're
doing social distancing wearing masks in
public washing your hands
and the lower we can get covert rates in
our community when this vaccine comes
out
the quicker the vaccine is going to have
its benefit
[Music]
in addition of the logistics of getting
this vaccine
where it needs to be the u.s marshals
are also
involved the agency which is better
known for tracking down fugitives and
transporting prisoners
will be protecting the doses as they
make their way
around the country gail very exciting
news thank you very much
manuel